in the last couple of videos we've gone
over the idea that the Federal Reserve
manages the money supply by setting a
target interest rate and there might
have been the obvious question circling
in your brain why don't they just manage
the money supply by instead of setting a
target interest rate why don't they set
a target money supply they could say
that we want the m0 to be make sure they
could say we have a target m0 of I don't
know 900 billion dollars and they just
if it's at 800 billion now they just
print that much 100 billion dollars more
of base money or Federal Reserve
deposits or Federal Reserve notes and
then the m0 will get to 900 billion and
then you'll have the multiplier effect
and more lending will take place and
then you will increase the m1 so
similarly they could have a target m1
they could say we want the m1 which is
the M 0 plus checking the deposit
account so essentially anything that can
be used for money so actual cash reserve
deposits or you know checking accounts
can be used for money because you can
write checks against them so they could
say we ought we want that target to be I
don't know two trillion dollars two
trillion dollars they can say we're
targeting the m2 m2 is the m0
well the m1 plus savings accounts and
money market account so they could say
we're targeting that to be eight
trillion dollars and just you know I
actually looked up these numbers as of
at least a 506 these numbers weren't
that far off the m0 was more like 800
billion but just so you get an idea
these are these are real numbers so the
obvious question is why don't they do
that why don't they just grow the money
supply maybe they say one thing they
could do they could say our goal is for
m2 to always be I don't know 50 percent
of GDP right they could say let's make
it always 50 percent of GDP so as the
economy grows we just have to make sure
that if it falls below 50 percent of GDP
that we just have to print a little bit
more money then it'll have a multiplier
effect and we'll just keep measuring it
if it goes a little bit above well we'll
do some open market operations and sell
and sell our Treasuries and take
reserves out of the banking system so
that's a completely legitimate way of
thinking about it and actually there are
some people who do advocate it this way
and I there is no clear answer to why
there
doing this but I thought about a little
bit and there's there's two reasons that
I can think of why this might make more
sense although there's there's a part of
me and maybe in a future video I'll make
an argument for why you this actually
doing something like managing the money
supply to 50 percent of GDP might
actually make a little bit more sense
but anyway the first reason is kind of
one out of convenience that the
short-term interest rate with which
banks lend to each other is just easier
to measure than any of these money
supply things if I'm Ben Bernanke and I
want to know what what what banks are
lending to each other at I could I could
just sample the market at that moment in
time I could say oh you know I'm a bank
when you're willing to lend to me at and
they'll say oh five point two percent
and like oh that's a little bit above
our target we have to buy more
Treasuries so you can get a very
real-time notion of where the market is
minute-by-minute you don't have to wait
for some surveys to get completed or
anything like that
while if you were targeting actual money
supply you would have to tabulate these
fairly quickly if you wanted real-time
information and that would just be more
of a mess to actually calculate the M -
you'd have to survey the banks and maybe
you can do some IT systems but it's
you're not going to get that real-time
information or at least it would be
harder to the other reason and this is a
little bit more abstract but I think
it'll make sense to you let's say it's
it's the autumn right no no let's say
it's the planting season I've never been
a farmer but I think the planting season
sometime in the spring and let's say
there's a couple of farm projects where
farm farmers need to borrow money to buy
seeds one of them returns a the farmer
will proceed if he can get lending at
20% or lower interest rates so if
someone's willing to lend him money
twenty one percent interest rate he'll
be like no that's way too much but if
you can get money at nineteen percent
interest rate he's like okay I'll borrow
the money and I'll buy the seeds because
I it it will create so much value that
I'll easily be able to pay that in fact
that interest say there's another farmer
with an 18%
project so if he gets 18% or lower
interest rates he'll proceed with his
project and let's say there's another
farmer with a let's say it's a 12%
project if he gets funding at 11% he'll
move forward and he'll buy the seeds and
he'll plant them and let's say there's a
couple of
projects in this universe let's say you
know there's a factory guy he's got a
really good idea new technology he wants
to invest in and he's going to move
forward building the factory if he can
get
I don't know nineteen percent funding
nineteen percent funding and let's say
there's another guy another factory guy
who would get I don't let me make it who
would get three percent funding so he's
not too confident about his project he
thinks that this project only makes
sense to move forward if he can get
three percent or better funding so when
I say better less than three percent my
phone is ringing but I'll ignore because
I'm on a roll and there's another guy
who's really marginal really [ __ ] he's
got a really shady project he himself is
not too confident in it he will only
proceed with this project if he
essentially gets money for free so this
is the state of affairs and in the
spring or during the planting season so
and these are the kind of the so all of
these would be potential consumers of
money and let's say that this is the
money supply let's say the money supply
is fixed at that moment in time so let's
say I have I'll draw the money supply
circles so there's three circles of
money right so essentially the money is
going to be lent to the people willing
to pay the highest interest rate so in
this case unless you know for sake of
simplicity assuming all of these are
kind of the same amount of money just
not to make things too complicated so in
a capitalist system the three best
projects will get the money and so it'll
be which ones it'll be this one this one
in this one right these three guys will
get the money and essentially they're
going to pay the lowest interest rate
they're going to pay the highest
interest rate that the worst amongst
them is willing to pay so this money is
going to go to these three guys and
essentially let's just say at seventeen
point nine percent Interest all right
seventeen point nine percent Interest
it's going to be lent to these three
guys right and I'm making a lot of
simplifying assumptions but I really
just want to get the underlying idea and
these projects these three projects are
not going to get done and you might say
well it's good that Society didn't
allocate money to this guy and this guy
because these were shady projects to
begin with
but it's kind of unfortunate this was a
twelve percent yield project
if somehow the capital was there we've
got a 12% return as on society which is
in the big picture of things a really
good project but there just wasn't
enough capital at that moment in time
there wasn't enough money at that moment
in time to support this project fair
enough but let's say the money supply
stays constant or at least in the medium
term over the course of the year because
that's what the Fed is targeting so as
we get away from the as we get away from
the planting season these projects
disappear these projects disappear
they're no longer there because the
planting season isn't there anymore and
let's say you know this guy got done but
let's say there's another project just
like it that's 19% and all of a sudden
since the planting season is done none
of the farmers want money anymore but if
you're keeping the money supply constant
now which projects are going to done
well this this good project here is
going to get done but so are these two
kind of crappy projects and they're
going to be lent at a much lower rate
they're going to it's going to you know
the average rate that it gets lent to is
going to be 1 or 2 percent or something
really low so what what you have a
situation here is that the money supply
did not it wasn't elastic with the
demand and the negative side effect to
society in this situation is when people
needed money we were passing on good
projects that really should have been
done because these were really safe
projects and then later when kind of the
timing is bad and we keep the money
supply constant bad projects will get
funded because there's just so much
money to go around and none of these
people need to use it that these really
crappy projects that might even be
negative I mean remember these are these
are what the investor thinks that
they're going to get but maybe there's a
lot of risk and these end up you know if
the investor thinks are going to get 1%
return maybe they made a mistake maybe
they'll get a minus 5% return in which
case we're going to be destroying wealth
so this is the problem where over a
medium period of time if you hold the
money supply constant you're not able to
you'll be passing up good you'll be
passing up on good projects when there's
a lot of demand for them and then you'll
be investing in bad projects when
there's a when there's not much demand
for projects on the other hand if you
had let's do the same scenario over
again like I made that a little messy
let's say you have a couple of farmers
again let me draw a line here so you had
the 20 percent 18 percent 12 percent
and then you had the in I'll draw ball
in yellow then you had the nineteen
percent three percent and one percent
now if if you had if you were managing
the money supply to an interest rate and
remember the interest rate the federal
funds rate is the rate that banks lend
to each other right but as we saw when
you inject reserves into the banking
system it lowers the rate that reserves
are lent to each other but it also
increases the lending capacity of banks
so it increases the money supply and so
when you increase the money supply
overall the lending capacity you're also
lowering the rate at which banks lend to
projects right you're increasing the
amount of money maybe the project's
haven't changed that much so more money
chasing the same number of projects the
cost of lending is going to go down
right so let's say the Fed manages the
interest rate in such a way that you
know that the Fed target rate was 5
percent but let's say that turns into
bank lending to real projects at I don't
know at 8 percent at 8 percent right so
in this case we're not fixing the money
supply we're just adjusting the money
supply in such a way that the interest
rate is fixed so now during the planting
season which projects are going to get
funded this one this one this one and
this one and these guys are not going to
get funded and then once the planting
season is over we're still keeping the
interest rate the same maybe we'll
contract the money supply in order to
keep interest rate and of course this is
what they manage do they manage to the
interbank lending but it's all related I
just want to give you a sense of why it
makes more sense to manage to an
interest rate so once the planting
season is over and some of these
projects aren't really available as
projects what were the these were all
the planting projects in this situation
when we had a constant money supply we
would lend to these crappy projects but
now that we keep the interest rates
constant or relatively fixed
still only the good project is going to
get funded and we don't have to worry
about banks just because they're chasing
yield and they're so flushed with cash
that they're chasing bad projects so
that's the underlying rationale at least
from my point of view why it makes sense
to manage to an interest rate as opposed
to a money supply it allows the money
supply to expand
and contract naturally in real time
according to market demands for cash and
by setting the interest rate you're
essentially setting the threshold over
which you're willing to let projects
only that meet that threshold get funded
and not you know projects below it that
might somehow waste money anyway we'll
discuss this a lot more in a lot of
different videos and hid it from
different angles but I just wanted to
answer those questions just so you know
that you know this wasn't some
convoluted crazy thing that they're
doing although it is a little bit
convoluted it's just not that crazy
anyway see you in the next video